hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is an award-winning architect
who's made a name for himself with his
unique sustainable architecture the
Aveeno of horseys cafe is originally
from burkina faso but now has his own
architectural practice here in Berlin
with various projects underway in
different countries around the globe
welcome to the show and you've just
you've just flown in I think from Venice
anywhere yes yeah but I wonder start we
would talk about your architecture and
how extraordinary it is coming up but I
want to start sort of at the beginning
in Burkina Faso as a young boy son
I think eldest son of the village chief
and and at the age of seven yes that you
had to leave the village to go to school
yeah elsewhere I mean that must have
been tough yes but there's so how you
have to do in Burkina Faso when you're
born in a country where there is not
enough schools you have to move your
family to be able to attend education I
did it simply when I was seven I almost
first leave my family love my parents my
friends are my community yeah we should
explain where Burkina Faso is because it
is in West Africa and to the north is
Mali
am i right yes up and you tell us the
rest so in burkina faso is simply
surrounded by Mali
yeah every course Ghana Togo Benin and
Niger and it's a landlocked country yes
yeah exactly and did you have then all
your education away from home oh yes and
where you with we were you with another
member of the family
no so did you I mean you left your mum
and dad but where you I thought you were
with an uncle somewhere
yeah with a real acting young yes ah so
I leave my family to be able to attend
primary education was in tank order is a
city somehow 20 kilometer from
my home village far and that for or for
this reason I had to leave in a in a
house of a relative yes are away from my
family and then I mean almost this is
moving on a few years you came to
Germany was that your first time abroad
actually oh yes yes what was that like
only to Germany I must be acquired
experience yeah yeah is a isn't his
experience I don't want to miss and it
is still fresh so imagine you take a
plane flight from Burkina Faso took up
from Wagga do go the capital city of
Burkina Faso
use us take off and you flies and flies
and then realize that trees are coming
is getting greener and greener and you
land to the aviary course and you take
there another flight to Nigeria from
there to London and then to German it
was amazing it really amazing I spend
the entire flight time watching down
until i hada weeks later headaches and
everything so yeah and that was just the
arrival the trees were the big thing I
mean you were coming actually I think to
be a carp to learn carpentry that is
true so so and and how did that where
was that that was at the the technician
University no no no no I was going to
suggest came to Germany because I I got
a scholarship to be to attend our
training s our development activists in
carpentry that you imagine there is no
wood in Burkina Faso and that's what I
was coming I was gonna say I could half
and her from there's not a lot of trees
no there is not not a lot of trees no
would incur country is very primitive so
we have no wood simply about in fact
coming to Germany was a change to escape
you know to move from Burkina Faso where
everything is limited there is no way to
attend food education so
I was simply lucky to get this
scholarship to escape my environment and
to enter another environment where
everything seemed to be available and
possible and here you were in Berlin yes
how did the change come to architecture
then ah so as a kid in Burkina Faso our
being working very hard part of this job
was about going to collect buildings
material and to fix housing of my
relative in whom house I was living in
when I was going to primary school in
Burkina Faso and I think as a kid I
wanted to do things better when I become
adult so that is why I had always this
this wish to learn how to gear to make
better housing this is simply that one
reason another reason was sitting in a
classroom in Burkina Faso with more than
150 other kids so in a little room let
me say less than 50 kilometer so I was
always dreaming and it's also was hot in
this building so I was dreaming to make
things there better also so I wanted to
build better classes I think those
things came together and this is how I
start to study architecture yeah but hey
were in Berlin we're doing carpentry how
did you manage to get into the Technical
University where I mean I don't know
about a few years ago but today to study
architecture there there's I don't know
let's say there's a hundred kids for
five places or ten places no but simply
when I came to Berlin I didn't have my
high school degree mm-hmm you have to
know that I had to go again back to
school but this time in an evening
school in Berlin unless and I made it
for five years in German yes and that's
how you learn German I guess yes yes
and it at night every day except with
except to Saturday and Sunday I went to
school from 6 o'clock p.m. to 11 o'clock
p.m. to be able to to do my high school
degree and then to go to Berlin to the
TU to study architecture okay
I was waiting about schools I mean let's
have a look at some of the extraordinary
buildings you've designed and a bit
about your life also here in Berlin do
you bid or franceska he left his
homeland more than 20 years ago and he's
been on the move ever since he has
architectural projects all over the
world but those closest to his heart are
in his homeland Burkina Faso Kerry works
with simple materials designing elegant
efficient buildings using resources
available locally
and he develops new ideas like this
double roof that allows the air to
circulate and cost-efficiently cool the
school bus is my eyes what I do is look
to see what I can take from Germany to
Burkina Faso not transfer it one to one
but translated to suit the local needs
in that respect I am building a bridge
between Germany and Burkina Faso and
Bukovina Korea's biggest project is the
Opera village in Burkina Faso a dream of
the late artist Kossoff Lindsey his
widow
I know Lawrence is still working with
Harry his school created from mud bricks
has won him global Fame as is einen it's
necessary to create buildings that can
get by without air-conditioning or
artificial ventilation without
intellectual dascomb he left burkina
faso so he could return he wanted to
find an architectural style suitable to
his impoverished country in western
Africa now he's active around the world
redesigning an old military barracks in
Mannheim and preparing a project
Beijing's Biennale his office studio in
Berlin is a multicultural laboratory and
his second area has protested light
penetration inside light we definitely
go through which ways will be exciting
yeah that here in Berlin I love the
solitude that I can sometimes do
something on my own
but Burkina Faso will always be my real
home Carrie doesn't just want to copy
architectural styles in Europe but to
observe and learn wherever he happens to
be the elementary school he built in
gundo is a model for all of Burkina Faso
and one in the other Khan award for
architecture next door and airy library
is under construction
again using local resources could a
developed his own recipe for making
bricks 8 buckets of cement added 292
buckets of clay this mixture mix has
buildings resistant to rain and termites
he learned to work with clay at an old
brickwork factory in Germany the hobby
thought that's where I learned how they
used to mix and sends the clay here and
I helped make the casts and learn how
you get the clay out of the molds and
roll it and then bang into the mold
scrape it flat and so on it was
wonderful una ba
Germany streets have become as familiar
to him as the dusty savannah he likes a
lot about Germany but some things are
still alien to him manche mother mrs.
sometimes I miss the spontaneity of life
but I always have that in burkina vitae
hindi bikina in Gondo he's building
houses for teachers and an extension of
his school he's determined that despite
a minimum of resources and adverse
conditions he'll find a unique aesthetic
for Africa that's a promise he's made to
his country he Biddulph on seas carry
our guest today on the insight Germany
and we were talking before that report
about how you managed to study
architecture how did you manage to set
up a business in Berlin after you'd
finish your architectural studies you
know that's quite tricky isn't it
setting up a business and yeah no but I
just did things in parallel while
studying in Berlin I started to think
about how to build schools in my school
in my own village in ganda so you have
to know that I build my very first
project a primary school in Gondolin my
home village when Asti was still a
student
I was studying and they just hop did it
and I graduate of three years later so
so I didn't have a plan to make a
business or who knows things just came
from alone hmm
so was a.cian assisity that lead me to
build a school because when I leave my
village there was no school and I I
guess instead of bringing present to
have a big family you have to know that
instead of bringing presents to my
village I just wanted to give something
to give education to max goodbye that's
quite a big present Europe will come to
the school I want to talk a bit in
detail about that just before that
though you also said in that report you
love the solitude of Berlin and that
struck me because that this of how many
million people are here
what's where's the solitude Oh
it's so of course nowadays people knows
me and now me but you have to know that
in this big big city you have time to go
to retire yourself you may be in a
public but not everybody knows you so
and then ganda where you come from
andhra can't do nothing or even in
burkina faso somehow people knows me and
they just came and in Gando special
especially if i am there
i have to act people just came to speak
to a disk cache to ask for some advices
ok so to share you know and so in these
contexts being in berlin being able to
go for example in a big symmetry so
which is green and quiet is a colorless
solitude but when you were initially in
Gondo and you started building the
school yeah I believe the locals were
actually a bit disappointed didn't they
expect sort of I don't know Guggenheim
Museum steel and things and they were
this is what's extraordinary about your
open architecture you use local things
we saw making the bricks for instance
yes well how to build in a reason like
Burkina Faso how to build in a country
which has a past a colonial past you
know with a western country so very
simple but when I arrived home
explaining to my people damn I am here
to build a school together with them and
I already have the money you have to
know that everybody was like over the
moon it was really happy and then I
explained them that we are going to use
clay to use math so I have to say that
there was shock really there was really
chalk the rejection was so big never he
wanted to speak again with me and it
cost me a lot of energy and then
discussions to convince them that this
is the only way to do a school will
respond the best to the climate and to
our net that is it but at the beginning
was no there was not open for that idea
no no
and you gave us you sent us some
pictures and this one to us most
probably unsure guys standing on a curve
there but there's there again if you
look closely at the guys they all look
petrified yeah this is a great story you
know the problem I have always it is how
to explain drawings and engineering to
people who are neither able to read nor
write so what I do is to build a model a
mock-up but a moral one by one in this
case in this case was a um was a piece
of the roof structure so we made it one
by one out of clay bricks and then I
have to I cannot jump jump in this
studio but normally I could jump on top
of that structure yeah so that my people
understood that it is working it will in
one crash so that is the test so to
check the engineering so that how we
will build it but this next one is the
roof you now yeah
this roof is meant to make it cooler and
eat this is not the locals in Burkina
Faso this is me I see a steel roof yeah
I know the temperatures in Burkina Faso
and I think of the Sun beating down on
that roof and it's got to be hotter
underneath yeah but it isn't it isn't
these are a smart idea you know just to
use the Sun they affect the negative of
effect of the sand to ventilate inside
the classroom so if you have a structure
you have a the metal shaped like this
and you open the roof and inside down
you have a massive skin made out of clay
of bricks okay so you create a certain
ventilation you push the air to
circulate between the two two elements
it's that way so
the hot air inside the two elements is
escaping from one side and absorbing the
inside ear so it's very simple fresh air
are coming from the side through the
windows it is very simple but it really
works yeah I end and another thing you
saying about using local materials this
picture also tells the story because
there's lots of parts in burkina faso
will show that briefly as we can see the
women they're bringing the pots and then
if i can show another of your buildings
which has got the sort of pots cut up
yes on the top and this is another form
of vented ventilation or the same
principle passage i don't know yeah and
there's the the and that steel structure
on top is the is the roof before it's
yes and i would have again said of
course the Sun beating down but of
course it works with your theory yeah
it's really works you need to have
openings you know hot air is escaping
always on the top yeah so you cause if
you if for example to to experience it
with Western world you have to heat your
wheel or your apartment if you hit your
apartment and the guy up to you is not
heating his apartment your energy is
going through the the ceiling and any
heating you have to heat his apartment
so the hot air is escaping from the top
yes so I just use this principle making
her openings in the ceiling so just let
the hot air escape so you create a
natural ventilation this has been
extraordinary successful in Gandhi I
mean I now believe there are over 700
children being educated there when there
weren't any being educated there when
you were seven years old um how did you
get the teachers though as well because
of course this is another size nothing
in a way to do with architecture but
you've got to get the teachers to go to
Gondo sort so if you build a school it
this is not enough
so you need teachers what we do is to
collaborate with the government the
government is sending teachers and pay
them so what I have to do is to provide
infrastructure such as housing for them
a teacher is a an educated person in
Burkina Faso of course hmm and you don't
want to stay in a village what we do is
to provide them with very comfortable
housing so to attract them so so that is
how we do but for long term you have to
cooperate more with the teacher to
improve also teaching so the electricity
rate in Burkina Faso is high but a thing
to go forward you have to improve the
quality of teaching today in Ghana I am
really proud to tell you that I was the
first one to be able to read and write
but we have more than as you could see
we have more than 700 kids and they're
all reading and writing yes this is yeah
this is a big step and how how is this
financed as well I mean I know that the
shoe by Louis Steiner for Gondo in
German translation would be building
blocks for ganda was this money you
gathered here in Germany with well how
did you finance it yeah so how I work
how I finance is very simple here in
Germany I collect money from some
friends but at the beginning of all I
collected money from my my colleague at
heat when I was studying huh as you have
to know that at that time I lost all of
my friends because I came with a box is
a model of the school that I build
myself and asking for support
fortunately today a lot of them just
admire how I worked I could achieve this
but collecting the money is not enough
so you have to convince the community to
work with you so I'm using the little
money I could collect and then I
convinced the people to be part of the
building process so that together we can
build great bill
for less money so that is how I do so
you see if you are in Gondo you will see
women with pot on their head walking to
the side to the building site so
everybody put his little stuff to get
this thing happening so it helps save
money and there is another aspect in
this project that people don't know it
is education even the adult need
education we train the young people in
the technique we apply to building
schools so they can't earn money they
become professionals working in
different building site now
it runs from burkina faso from Gandil to
other cities places in burkina faso to
the neighboring countries also Ghana
Togo been in so you see something really
gathering moss and yes exactly there's a
part from the financial side you also
made friends or got the attention of a
very famous German artists who we must
briefly talk about because in the first
report it talked about an opera village
yeah and I was thinking if it's
corralled oh where where Klaus Kinski
builds an opera in the Amazon jungle
this was because of a man called Crystal
schlingman zeef tell us about him how
did he get how did you get involved or
how did he get involved in your project
I the Opera village I'm curse off sing
as if um unfortunately he's not alive
anymore he passed away in 2011 I was a I
crazy is not a good word but he was our
it genius let me say that he has he had
a dream he wanted to be an opera in
Africa and then our ways cross so I was
giving a lecture and leading a workshop
his house is held as houses in the in
South Africa and people connect us and I
got to meet him and he had this dream
but to be honest I am fighting to build
schools in Burkina Faso and somebody
came with an idea to build an Oprah you
could imagine Maria
my natural reaction so is a provocation
is not serious so I'm straggling to
build schools to educate people you can
with an idea of an opera opera even in
the Western world is something that is
really limited to there to the 2% of the
population you understand what I mean
and then but by the way then we happen
to mate and he was so a great person has
a strong personality and he made these
ideas so attractive so yeah we start to
do the project okay
Christoph schlenz Eve was an
extraordinary man let's have a look in a
little more detail at the career of this
rather controversial artist he's sorely
missed few artists have had this said
about them quite so often radical
iconoclastic performance artist and
director christoph shingen's 'if he died
in 2010 why do we miss him so much
last year an exhibition in Berlin was
seeking an answer to this question
he was the first comprehensive sring and
zeef retrospective but how can a museum
do justice to someone as multifaceted as
he was
clean zeef wasn't afraid of anything
he created theater art and opera and
made in your face splatter movies into
woven with German history in 1998 he
founded the political party chance 2000
or in English the last chance party
which also staged this happening in
Vienna shingen's Eve's own version of
the television show Big Brother putting
asylum seekers in containers as always
many thought he was going too far
chance mm a blend of politics art and
play shrinkin zeef issued a call for
four million unemployed to take a dip in
the wharf gangs a lake in austria and
raised the water level there by flooding
German Chancellor Cole's vacation home
of course it failed but schlinger zebes
motto was failure his opportunity in
2003 he had unemployed people sit around
and wait for posts at the Berlin
exhibitions students took on this job a
pale copy of the original idea yet
another provocation his 2004 staging of
vogner's pasa file in Beloit a marathon
of shock and salvation a scandal was
guaranteed wounds myths kitsch the
exhibition was a journey through German
history
it also documented how shilling and zeef
lived with cancer as in his project for
the Venice Biennale a church of fear of
the stranger in me undeterred in 2008 he
pulled out all the stops and founded
what he called his opera village in
Burkina Faso complete with a hospital
and a school he continued writing
struggling and venting his anger and his
fear brutally honest and still loud but
increasingly quiet
Christophe sling conceived a bit mad a
bit maniac but always a maverick a
maverick indeed and the what is the
state of affairs actually with the Opera
village I know that since he died it's
still going on yes his widows helping
with the project and yes
and some celebrities as well yeah yeah
since he passed away we keep doing the
project he unfortunately he couldn't see
the project so but we open three years
ago
so just in 2002 we opened the first
school building now and 150 kids are
attending a primary education in the in
the Opera village mm-hmm so I thought
about the Opera and such and
self-administer is it gonna I have opera
there as you're gonna have something
different yeah whatever
the Opera itself is still part of the
project the vision but it's not an opera
I like you may imagine it should be a
but we have a space we have this
infrastructure where different
activities are already happening on the
site sometimes supported by the German
we go to Institute the German cultural
institution so that we make performances
and then dancing whatever a lot of
activities are happening there but the
most important thing is education is
still happening
in two weeks three weeks we will open a
nursery which is part of it Christoph
himself once happened to say that a cry
of the newborn is an opera so maybe if
all of these happening you may
understand that is not opera in the
classical way it not no in the opera
light you would imagine in Europe so
it's a performance space yes and we'll
have all sorts of things
perhaps not la bohème or something by
Puccini absolutely we'll have all sorts
of diction and backed by people like I
believe the author Henning Mankell and
have a grandma the famous German sing
and these people are still backing the
product yes yes we have a lot of friends
that are supporting the project the
German the former German president horse
Cola is a protecting and supporting the
project so and then you have all of
these earth people that are supporting
us honestly so to keep things go but
money is a problem we have to say
because it's a bill is a huge project
and I know the widow of Christoph is a
struggling to find to find fun to get
the project go ahead I'm still
supporting the project with my
architecture I am the contact and I am
flying to Burkina to supervise the
ongoing project and then the building
that are in process here yeah it's it's
going we've talked mainly about the
projects in burkina faso like to you
sends a couple other pictures if you get
as Helles this ones is this in one in
china yes
and then that that's more the architect
that architecture that I would
understand or looks like it is this more
conventional if you like yes somehow I
got a shines to work with a great
Chinese architect one shoe is a good
friend of mine and I just asked him you
know what these people expect from me
you know what I'm doing I'm using mud
mostly in Burkina to build schools what
can I do what can
how can I contribute it he just tell me
you know keep doing open spaces like you
do and then you will know and for myself
having to China to learn it's really not
the modern stuff but China is so very
old and has old techniques I was
interested in these old techniques so
that is why I'll end up in up to start a
project in China mm-hmm and this is
another project or yeah it architectural
well it is an exhibition wasn't it yeah
in London I believe yes it's a great
installation in London in the real
academia right so it has been successful
I don't know if you have more picture
about that I do so I invited the part of
that debate to contribute it to to build
up these ice English this is the second
picture and is that done by the public
then yes oh I didn't know that
yes well no no simply because if you
invite me to do something in London in
ganda I will use mat or something else
and in London what is available in
London so I have realized that you have
a lot of honey camp
it is hided everywhere in every
furniture
I just wanted to expose this project it
is material so creating a channel and
inviting the people inviting the visitor
to contributed not to stay in and just
watch but to be part of the new kind of
sticks yeah a logistics and they could
just look yes well I long yes oh yeah I
think it has been a big success really
because people just you to put there to
contributor to build is a structure Andy
and are you I mean seeing that and the
what are the pictures before this was
not like the pictures in Gondo and using
locomotive this was using modern
technologies that yes the way you're
going more now yeah is no it's about if
I am London I mean England is the
country of modern technology is the
country of Industry realization so I may
use industrial products to build a
because this is the most
available product so industrial product
so in Gondo we use material we use clay
this is the most building material so
somewhere else i may use something
different yeah if you talk about Geneva
where I have the chance to make the
permanent exhibition of the
International Red Cross Museum using a
hemp you know hemp yeah is known as you
use it in inner inner fabric so but you
can use it to beer it is a very good
insulation material okay is it to get oh
and another thing that architects are
beginning to use is 3d printing we'll
see if our guests has use that in a
minute but they say that it's possible
to print your own food why you want to
do that is beyond me Marcel and now you
can print your own house and I wonder
straight away what that's like to heat
but anyway here's more this column has
come out of the printer and it's part of
a 16 square meter room more than two and
a half meters high
it weighs 11 tons and is the latest
innovation in the world of architecture
it's made of artificial sandstone and it
has ornamentation reminiscent of a
Gothic cathedral
Mihal Hans Meyer and Benjamin Dylan
Berger from the Technical University in
Zurich are the brains behind the
creation which they called the digital
grotesque we seen it in the past in the
pre pre modern days that architecture
was created with an incredible level of
detail if you look at baroque churches
if you look at the Rococo and so on but
it took an incredible amount of time it
took artisans years and years and years
to to create something like this they
completed their room in just a few
months using an algorithm to calculate
every angle and curve and to create
shapes that possibly couldn't be done by
hand the 3d printer is indeed breaking
new boundaries
using the 3d printer it takes just two
days to apply the layers of fine sand
they are then stocked to the artificial
stone once it has set any excess sand is
removed from the mold and can be reused
the team has assembled the component
parts to make a solid walk in room
architects in Amsterdam are going a step
further on March 1st they will begin the
construction of the first printed
building it's a canal side house made of
plastic a specially designed machine
will print the component parts on-site
and they will then be assembled in much
the same way as a toy house 3d printing
that's like speed and materials at the
moment with this pace of growth in mega
cities the current construction
techniques is not sufficient enough
maybe that's why we also believe that 3d
printing can actually make a big
difference in 5 10 20 years time other
European architects are also developing
concepts for printed houses the
Amsterdam based company universe
architecture is planning what it calls a
landscape house from artificial
sandstone Foster and partner are working
with the European Space Agency to create
a moon base that would be printed on
site using moon sand the London company
soft kill design has an equally
innovative project the structure of
their building imitates bone growth the
artificial sandstone of the zurich based
project is not strong enough yet to
withstand wind and weather but the
architects are convinced that it's only
a matter of time before it will be
and when it is people will be able to
live however they wish
my guest is falsely scary the celebrated
architect do you think people will be
able to live however they like because
of this so I mean you use a bit of 3d
printing but not on that ski are not on
that size it's some I may say this is a
3d printing help you if you have a model
which is a delicate to do if you want to
help to be more precise yeah some may be
able to put to print but it's not an is
is a production principle or a process
it's a processes you know is the new way
of producting is like preffer so if they
use it but it much more precise I I
think that this will help solve a lot of
problems so increase the speed to be RIT
you know if you're buying in the city
yeah so why not we are in the 21st
century we have a lot of opportunities
we have a lot of possibilities so it's
good to to explore them yeah your next
project we haven't got pictures of
because it's so new the layo clinic hmm
this is you you told me before we came
on as a sort of a bit more of a holistic
approach even more so than Gondo
yeah leo is a good example for us so
because or everywhere every time when I
start a new project I am trying to do
something new to explore something new
it might be a material but it may be you
know energy so in labor so you may
imagine it very simple we use clay it is
locally available to build a structure
and then we use solar panels to collect
the Sun energy transforming it into
electricity which is now but because we
have no electricity we have no power in
lay
in this site and what we do is to
collect the water
greywater whatever you use in this
clinic and to clean it using electricity
that you have fun of for free you
understand and I heard it again in the
six Sigma's so okay that that's one
project I want to just briefly ask you
about your project in general because
you're doing a huge project in Mannheim
as well oh yes you've become the master
of reinventing barracks not maybe it may
be our specialist of converting is
better than inventing no we gotta-we was
part of the competition team and we were
warned the competition is about taylor
barracks 46 hectare is huge that's you
yeah it's a big area and then to - we
are making the master plan where you
have different users especially
especially industrial so and that is
what working on and the idea we had is
to put green through this area that was
closed for years you know and to give
something back to the population but the
way keeping economical expectation also
know will we now we're working on that
we're working since two years it it's
yeah it's a great project well it's been
fascinating talking about all sorts of
different architecture that you're up to
I wish you all great luck before we go I
think we've just got about a minute we
have a questionnaire we haven't had time
to talk about a bit one of the things
you put in it if I remember rightly is
and one of the best things about living
in Germany I just find energy was was
the weather yeah it's I thought you
might have put has one of the worst
things about living in Germany the best
thing is the weather so good looking
afar so you have dust in Germany you
have no that's now just you're for sure
you don't have that much Sun like as in
burkina that you have no - some in some
areas you have no flies and mosquito
so Dez's Amit this is great
so you quite like the winter then in
Germany oh yes I may say I am very
difficult am i a lot I am sometimes
controversial yes I love winter
I love the calm - quite nice
oh yeah I love it when the snows on yes
Frances we have to leave it there forces
carry it's been fascinating really
because I know nothing I now know
something about architecture I'm
wonderful sustainable architecture
thanks very much for being with us today
thank you for watching if you'd like to
get in touch with us please do so right
- insight at a DW de if you want to know
more about any of processes wonderful
things that he's doing projects we'll
get back to bye bye now see you next
time
thank you